التقى بيتر وليزا مارشال
ووقعا في الحب وفي عام
2009 أقام حفل زفاف في صورة مثالية
ذكرى كان من المفترض أن تستمر مدى الحياة
ولكن قبل ثلاث سنوات تم تشخيص بيتر
بمرض الزهايمر المبكر
في سن 53. لقد نسي
أن ليزا كانت له  الزوجة بدأ
يخبرني بكل شيء
عن زوجته وكان يتفاخر بزوجته لي ،
لذا كان ذلك مفيدًا
لكنني علمت أنه أحب زوجته ،
فأصبحت ليزا ببساطة مقدم الرعاية المفضل لديه
ولكن لا يزال لديهم شرارات كنا
نشاهد
حلقة جديدة  فتاة وكان هناك حفل
زفاف ، نظر إلى التلفزيون وكان لديه هذه
الابتسامة الصغيرة المتعجرفة على وجهه
وقال لنفعلها وأشار إلى التلفاز إلى الزوجين اللذين
يتزوجان وقلت هل تطلب مني الزواج
منك وهو  قال نعم وأومأ
برأسه وابتسم أكبر
وكبير وصغير أفعل ، وهكذا في أبريل / نيسان
وجدت ليزا نفسها مرة أخرى عند
المذبح ، يشرفني ويسعدني أن أقول
لك مرة أخرى ، زوج وزوجة
بيتر ، يمكنك تقبيل عروسك
[موسيقى]
[تطبيق  lause]
ما كان في ذلك اليوم هو الجزء الأكثر سحرية
من كل شيء هو أنه
كان
معي من الناحية الإدراكية طوال اليوم وشعرت أنه
منذ 10 سنوات
وكان مفتونًا جدًا بالكل
معي في اليوم الذي شعرت فيه بحبنا
ممتاز الآن بعد أن
تزوجت مرتين ، هل يعرف أنك
زوجته
لا ولا يتذكر الحفل
الذي يمثل الخسائر الوحشية لمرض بيتر
ولكن بالنسبة لليزا كان المضي قدمًا في
حفل الزفاف فرصة نادرة
لأخذها  لحظة عابرة خاصة
وجعلها تدوم
هذه الذكريات التي قمنا
بتجديدها في الوادي كان بالنسبة لي
أن أعتز بها لبقية حياتي عندما
لم
يعد لدي بيتر بعد الآن من
يعتقد أنك
شخصه المفضل ، شخص
آمن الشخص  من يعتني به طوال
الوقت الذي يحبني كثيرًا ، أنت تعلم أنه
حنون جدًا ،
إنه يخدش ظهري ويقبلني ،
يعلم أن هناك حبًا
وعلى الرغم من أنه لا يستخدم كلمة
أن هذه زوجة ما أنت عليه
واصفا
نعم  لسنا بحاجة إلى تسميات تعرف أن
قلوبنا مرتبطة جدًا
بتقارير إليزابيث كوهين